wow I didn't I didn't realize there was
actually a campfire here this is very
cozy hello everyone so I'm going to gaze
into the haze here and ask for some
audience participation because the title
of my uh talk is How to Win Friends and
Influence decisions so first how many of
you have had to influence decision in
the last week or tried to influence a
decision so back in my previous Life as
a design leader I really thought that
that my job was to influence you know
design is about storytelling it's about
trying to have everyone else see what
the future is and Influence People
towards it then I thought you know one
day if I become a founder and I've got
my own company I could just tell people
what to
do then it turns out I did that and in
fact I actually have to influence more
than ever so all of you who think your
job you're going to get out of the job
of influencing unfortunately I'm here to
tell you that is not the
case but since I have you all here and
you are an amazing group of very
talented senior experienced product
leaders I'm going to ask for your help
you see I have a prior prioritization
question and I've got three options for
what our incredible team here should
do behind door number one we've got an
INF for rewrite which the engineers have
been clamoring for door number two all
the designers are saying our onboarding
experience really sucks and so we got to
we got to redo it and behind door number
three our CEO has been talking to all of
their other founder friends and gen AI
is the thing we got to add a new
feature so friends how many of you think
we should do the reite show up
hands I can tell which of you have an
engineering background from from this
okay redesign the onboarding experience
all right all right how about that
differentiated gen
feature we've been inspired by Claire's
talk from
before how many of you know that I'm
about to lead with a fourth slide that
tells you guys this is really not the
question
so yes um you know what it is pretty
hard to prioritize something like this I
feel like I'm constantly every single
week in discussions that sound similar
to to that and the reality of course is
it's hard because there's so many
variables and all sorts of questions and
things that come into every single
prioritization decision so we're going
to put that aside for now what I want to
talk about in this talk is actually what
is a good process that we can take that
gets us from look I have a strong
opinion because I'm sure many of you
here probably did have an inkling and in
all of your influence and prioritization
decisions you probably do have a strong
opinion how do we get from that to that
opinion actually shapes us towards a
better outcome so this going to be a
simple foolproof five-step process
ready so Step
One is very simple let us draw a circle
so do it with me now let draw draw a
circle what do I mean by
that well I love this story and this
quote this bet un quote because I think
it really encapsulates this picture
which is when it's just me at home with
my brother it's me against my brother
but when my cousins come over it's me
and my brother against the cousins and
then if the other neighborhood kids come
on over and they're going to challenge
us to something it's me my brother and
my cousins against that
group what I love about this is it
illustrates we get to choose where we
draw the circle do we draw the circle
around ourselves is it I need to
convince you that my idea here here is
the right one or are we going to draw
the circle more
broadly now no matter who it is that you
are disagreeing with and you're on
totally separate pages with and you're
trying to convince your company there is
a circle around you which is hey we all
work at this company and because we work
at this company we all care about the
company winning in fact if the company
wins we hate our goals we make a lot of
money Rising tide lifts all boat
and so there's always a way to draw a
circle where now it is you and the
person in the circle against whatever it
is that is the problem or the goal and
so the lines that you can use here is
just always always always start with
that always start with look what we
really want is to make sure that we make
a great product that our customers love
so now let's talk about the various
ideas or it is just really important
that we can achieve our Revenue targets
because otherwise we're not going to get
that roundout of funding or whatever
terrible thing is going to happen so
let's Orient around how we're going to
best do that and I think it's so
important it's not just these lines it's
the mentality that we have if you go
into a meeting thinking I need to
convince this person I'm right you've
just drawn the circle around
yourself but if you go in and you say
okay we're both in the circle together a
lot of this becomes so much more natural
and easy
and the energy I promise you is going to
be
different step number two so we drawn in
the circle step number two assume that
everyone is seeing the
truth what do I mean by that so this is
a story that I think about and I kid you
not I think about this probably three
times a week which is the parable of the
Five Blind Men and the elephant and so
the story goes there are five Blind Men
and they saunter into the woods and they
encounter an elephant for the first time
and so each of them is like this is our
opportunity we can really get to know
this
elephant so the first man says he goes
up and touches the elephant he say I
know what an elephant is the elephant is
rough and hard like a like a tree tree
trunk and then the second blind man goes
up and he touches elephant he's like you
are totally wrong totally wrong the
elephant feels like
leather and third blind man goes and
like you guys are both ridiculous the
elephant is like a
rope I actually forgot what the fourth
and fifth Blind Men said but I think you
get the gist of the
story now all of us who are blessed with
eyesight we can
see you know what they're all right they
are all seeing some version of the
elephant because the ear is like leather
and the legs are like a tree trunk and
the tail is like a rope but it's also
the case that none of them are
completely right they all see truth but
they don't see the whole truth and
whenever we disagree this is usually
what is happening we're all seeing some
version of the truth but it's not put
together in a way that lets us
cohesively understand
it and of course this is pretty obvious
because a lot of times look we do have
different experiences we have different
roles if you ask a designer to evaluate
a piece of work they go straight to well
what is the customer going to think is
it easy to understand does it feel
aesthetically pleasing if you talk to a
salesperson about the work they're going
to go straight into like what does this
mean for our Revenue targets everyone's
got a different perspective and it is
often the product leader job to hold
these different perspectives and to be
able to see the truth that is
encapsulated in each of these different
disciplines and of course it's not just
again between product managers or
product leaders you also see this right
some team is trying to optimize for
growth and retention and some other team
is trying to optimize for revenue and
they're going to be at odds because
sometimes the best thing for growth is
not the best thing for Revenue but
instead of being like I got to convince
them I got to convince them that they're
wrong just acknowledge and put on the
table the fact that we do see we all see
truth but we see a a version of it and
it is our job to acknowledge that and to
do our best to put these versions of the
truth together towards the greater good
and I love just being able to
acknowledge that in the in the beginning
of what is likely going to be us
discussing a different perspective right
look it really does seem like we see
things differently and but we all have
something valuable so let's just put
that on a table
or you can also sometimes you know call
it out in advance hey so you are a
designer so you more easily can spot
usability issues while I can more easily
spot the places in which you know
usability or pricing are going to come
into conflict but just acknowledge what
everyone brings to the table and that
helps them feel heard and helps them see
okay now we're now we can now that we've
realized that we all do see something
valuable we can more see everyone else's
perspective so so far we've drawn the
circle we have acknowledged that
everyone sees some truth this is where
the fun part begins step three is let us
be like detectives and uncover where
each of us sees the
truth and I'm going to move straight to
the lines that you can use because I
think that these are two very very
powerful
questions so now that you and I are both
Al that we want us to provide a great
customer experience while hitting our
Revenue targets what would we have to
both what would have to be true for us
to believe that we should do feature a
or what would have to be true for us to
generally agree that feature B matters
more another way of asking the question
is if I am advocating for a and you know
it and you are advocating for B is to
ask a question of hey well if you're
advocating for B what would convince you
that a is actually better for the goal
that we both aligned on in the
beginning so let's go back to those
questions we had at the beginning infer
rewrite why might infer rewrite be
actually the most important project for
us to
tackle
well if our performance is really
degraded let's say we have a lot of
customers and our performance has been
degrading and we're very concerned that
if the performance doesn't get better
our customers are going to churn that
would be bad both you and I don't want
churn and customers that would be a
disaster or let's say we're about to add
we assume that we're going to do a big
marketing push we're going to add a
bunch of new customers and the product
is so buggy that we're worried that
we're not going to make a good
impression and they're not going to
stick around that would be
bad or maybe the reason is just simply
it's so difficult to add new changes to
our code base that all of our Engineers
are really upset and morale is horrible
and they're all going to rage quit on
us now again these are extreme examples
but I think that actually talking about
the extremes is one tactic that brings
everyone else along because we can
always agree on the extremes and if we
can agree on the extremes what we do is
we start putting the prioritization
question as something on the table where
we're on the same side and we're just
trying to figure out what's the best
balance right so okay let's agree on
extremes that would both be bad if these
things happen we should do the info
reite but what about redesigning
onboarding
well onboarding really matters if we're
going to add a lot of new users is that
true are we going to add a lot of new
users and it would matter if we were
going to add a lot of new users and we
somehow knew that our product is
actually very good the product has
product Market fit but somehow these new
users are not understanding how to get
value out of the product that is where
onboarding would really matter right and
again reasonable people will likely you
know I'm seeing many of you nod like yes
this is what we can agree on and finally
what about a gen AI
feature well if this new technology
makes it 2x 3x 5x better for us to
deliver our value prop that would be
awesome we should do that or if we don't
do it and we're worried that all our
customers are going to go to competitor
because they're they're doing it and we
should probably prevent that as
well so in this case again reasonable
people will
agree and this brings us very well to
the next point which is once you have
these scenarios it's time to turn the
problem into a data
question so now that we've established
like in these extremes yes we can all
agree we should do that the question
becomes well are we in this scenario
and the specific questions that I find
so powerful are just simply asking well
how can we know it's really true that
the degraded performance is going to
cause a lot of our customers to turn or
what evidence do we have
that this new janaa idea is going to be
really well received in the market or
how can we quickly get signal on whether
it is the case that most of our
Engineers are so fed up with the
terrible quality of our code base that
they're about to rage quit and once you
start asking these questions I'm sure
you know your your brain is already
firing all of these different solutions
oh let's go do a survey or let's go talk
to our customers oh let's go and and
check that dashboard let's talk to the
data scientist and and do an ad hoc
analysis but once we all start asking
these questions like what evidence do we
have we can quickly figure out how to
get the answer and when I mean data I
mean it very broadly right data is just
any information that gives us a little
bit more context as to the questions
that we have so could be quantitative
could be talking to customer success or
interviewing sales or just getting on a
call with 10 customers or doing a
internal survey but all of that is going
to help us with some of those scenarios
that we were looking at before
so back to our examples we said look in
for reite if the performance is
degrading and are our customers are
going to churn well how was our
performance has it been getting worse
have we seen that correlate with churn
and the customer base or have we pulled
20 customers and said hey how do you
feel about the performance or how have
you felt about the bugginess of our of
our experience as of late right lots and
lots of ideas for how we could get a
little bit more evidence again we should
also by the way if you're a startup
maybe the fact that you don't have that
many existing users means it doesn't
matter that much if they churn because
you're putting a lot more eggs into
acquiring the next set of users but all
of these you know understanding where
you're turn understanding how many users
you have like what how many users do you
expect to add how unhappy are Engineers
this all give us evidence or data that
helps us become more clear about whether
we are in scenario one or two or
three similarly with
onboarding good questions to ask are
like well are we really adding a lot of
new
users in the next quarter in the next
six months and what is the current
retention and maybe what are what's good
retention look like for our our app in
the marketplace something we can ask our
Venture capist what is the usage of
these core features and is it true that
if we manually walk users through the
product and they get it
then they use it a ton versus when they
don't you know through through the
actual product experience um they don't
right that makes a real case that
onboarding is a great
lever and finally with adding
differentiated AI you know have we done
any quick experiments have we prototyped
things have we used chat GPT to answer a
bunch of these questions and see if it
actually dramatically helps us with the
value prop of what we're trying to do
have we gone and talked to Smart
customer custers hey we got five ideas
do any of these seem like they would
help you do your work or or uh achieve
your goals more efficiently and also of
course there's customer or there's
market research just looking around
asking around figuring out what else our
competitors doing and are we going to
get left
behind so lots of really great ways to
get more insight get more data but I can
see some of you thinking okay I got to
move really quickly who has time for all
that
and I agree with you because I work in
data and I can tell you that data will
never actually give you certainty as
much as we like to as much as
uncertainty is
uncomfortable we won't ever get the
certainty the best that we can get is
just a little more evidence a little
more insight at the end of the day most
of the decisions including the biggest
and most important decisions we're going
to have to make on a leap of faith
somebody has to make that decision and
so if you've gotten all the that you can
get or maybe you can't get that much and
you just have to move
on the question you should ask yourself
is okay maybe you and I still disagree
right we got all the data we looked at
the evidence we're on the same page you
know we drawn the circle but we still
don't disagree what should we
do and this is where it's time to move
the conversation up a level and make it
a people question who is now the best
person to make the call usually I find
it is far easier for people to agree on
who's the best person to make the call
than it is on what the specific decision
might be now again if you're in a large
orc there already may be naturally a
chain of escalation and you can follow
that but you don't always have to follow
it you know you can also say look you
and I since we're now in the same Circle
we we know that this person is really
deeply invested in the end goal and for
this particular decision they have the
best combination of context and skill
both are important if you're going to
make a decision on what's the right new
technical infrastructure do not ask me I
don't have the experience to make that I
could have all the context but I'll
still probably make a bad decision
whereas um if even if somebody has the
skill but they just don't they don't
know they don't have the data they don't
have the history the context they still
may not be the best person to make
thisis so you need both best combination
of context and
skill now as a product leader what is so
powerful about this is that you can
actually Point towards and nominate the
person to make the call it doesn't have
to be the same person that makes every
decision in fact that would be
suboptimal because no single person is
the best at having the right context and
skill to make every decision so in
certain cases this is where you can
nominate hey this decision is a lot more
about how we can improve um the the
technical infrastructure so for the
product I nominate the enge leader or
this this this particular initiative is
much more about how we can improve the
customer experience and I'm going to
nominate that in this case we should
just listen to the design leader on on
this you do not have to be the person
who makes all the decisions or knows
what the answer is you have to just make
sure the best decisions get made and one
of your biggest lovers is getting better
at identifying who is the best at making
which
decision finally of course you want that
person person to be clear D and calm
they don't have a bone to pick they're
not out for Revenge they're not so
stressed out about whatever it is going
on that is the person who is ideally the
candidate for making the
call so here are some lines you can use
I know that founder mode is all the rage
now so you just pull it out there guys
we need a found remote this so I
recommend I make the call it's also okay
to nominate yourself
but make it so that everyone feels like
they can share in the fact that we're
all doing this again to drive the best
outcomes for our
team so let's say you do all this okay
you do all this you got the data you
nominate a person and you still feel
like ah we made the wrong
call what do you do are we are we done
by the way all everything I've said so
far it does not guarantee that you're
going to get what you want all the
time but the game is not over because
I'm a big believer that time eventually
reveals more and more
truth so what can happen is we did
everything but you're you're sure you're
certain that this was the wrong
call write that down write down
document you know if you have a
documentation culture it will be written
down but document hey three people
didn't think we should do this and four
people did and we nominated X person to
make decision or you know our our VP as
and and we made decision X but remember
who made what call and that way after
one month or three months or six months
or a year go back and look at what
happened did the decision bear
fruit if yes there's a lot to learn from
that did the decision not bear fluit
also a ton to learn from that but I
think this is so important for us to
have a practice of in fact what I like
to do is put a calendar invite for
myself at these time frames so after we
make a major call one month later I'll
say go back and think about that
decision we made three months later six
months right you will learn different
things at different time frames because
the story is evolving as we live
life and so when you go back and you
watch your replays and you go back and
evaluate what was the outcome of these
decisions there's many many layers of
what it is that you learn now the most
obvious the ones that we end up talking
the most about as product people are
well what did we learn about our
customers and their needs and secondly
what did we learn about our product and
the levers you know is pricing a lever
is onboarding a lever is putting more
power user features a lever for
monetization or what whatever it is that
we're trying to
drive but I want us to go further as
well because Beyond those layers there's
also the layer of hey are we actually
measuring things in the right way are we
sure that we know what success looks
like because metric goals can change and
it's my experience having worked and and
looked at you know the history of many
things that sometimes you think that
what you have is a growth problem and it
turns out over time it's a retention
problem you you know what you learn is
that retention matters more and once you
realize retention matters more over time
you might refine that further retention
of this particular customer segment
matters more because they are the ones
that actually lead the most to our
ability to monetize and and have like
great uh monetization retention so how
what we learn about the way that we
measure success is a third layer right
um beyond that we can also learn how do
we make decisions I love the previous
talk because it was about that it was it
was the learning is not necessarily
about what is the decision but how do we
come together and do better product
reviews how do we improve the
decision-making process should we spend
more time doing getting evidence or are
we are we repeating the same
conversations over and over and we
actually need to move a little faster
right so there's a meta layer about how
we make decisions and then finally and I
think this is the most underrated what
did we learn about the quality of each
person's individual ual
judgment because at the end of the day
thinking about influence is thinking
about the people problem and the people
Dynamics so
if your executive is making 10 decisions
in a row about some Dimension it turns
out over time he's wrong I hope the
conclusion that the entire company can
come to is this person is not to be
trusted
on whatever it is that that they're
making so this and you're not going to
know this until you keep the score and
you continually go back and
reflect and this is very important for
the self as well right we like to go in
we're product people we pride ourselves
on having great judgment about what it
is with product and there are going to
be areas where you have biases I have
biases I guarantee it and we're not
going to learn about that until we do
this over and over
again so to recap we're going to start
by drawing our Circle
we assume that we're all seeing parts of
the truth like the Blind Men and the
Elephant we're going to try and be like
detectives and together figure out where
the truth applies in these extreme
examples then we're going to see what
evidence do we have right turn it into a
data question and if we don't have time
to gather our data eventually turn it
into a people question and finally we're
going to continue to watch our replays
I want to end on a Zen Buddhist concept
so this is a character called
moo and literally it means nothingness
but in the Buddhist
tradition it's meant to refer to this
idea that
sometimes the true answer the best
answer is much greater and vaster than
the question that was originally
posed it is often the case that the
question we're asking is too narrow of a
question in this case we started out
with prioritizing the info rewrite or
the onboarding or adding a
differentiated AI
feature but if you if you look into the
future 3 months 6 months a year later
there actually many many possibilities
for what a great outcome could look
like perhaps we realize we need better
instrumentation and measurement perhaps
we realize we should do all these it's
more a matter of sequencing than if we
should do these things perhaps we
discover that actually wow once we dug
into retention we realize we have a
retention problem and there's in fact 20
other ideas we have for how to improve
retention maybe we came up with a better
process for how we work
together a story that I think about a
lot is that back in Facebook's history
history things were going well they're
growing growing growing viral social
network until one day growth
stopped and what Mark did was task a
small group of people to go and solve
the growth problem get us back on track
so that we can grow
again and the team came up with a lot of
ideas hypotheses tested and so
forth I don't remember what was the idea
or the lever or the thing that they did
that started growth again but I can tell
you the process that they uncovered the
culture of growth the way that they
became more data informed the framework
that they develop that turned out to
blossom into a an incredible cultural
set of practices that every single team
at Facebook adopted and is still a core
part of what makes Facebook Facebook
today that is the true gift that is the
thing the gift that keeps on
giving so in conclusion you know what
problems are going to come and go
there's going to be a decision to make
today tomorrow next year there's going
to be tens of thousands of decisions
that you're going to make and that your
and your team are be together going to
make but relationships but the learnings
the people the wisdom these things are
forever these things are rare figuring
out how to do that well and enjoy the
process with the people that you work
with that is the truest gift I can think
of nothing better than waking up every
morning and just excited to come into
work and solve problems with people we
like instead of feeling like it's a
fight every day I think that is what we
should be trying to optimize
for thank you everyone
[Applause]